In the previous lesson, we talked about object-oriented analysis, the process by
which you can begin to come to understand the problem you're trying to solve.
Today, we're going to talk about how would you express the results of
that understanding using the Unified Modeling Language, UML. In particular,
we're going to talk about UML's Class Model Diagram, which is the most popular
form of UML. Besides being popular, it's also the most complex
of the diagramming types in UML. However, there's no need for you to use all of
its features, particularly at the start of the modeling process.
There's nothing wrong with having an abstract version that you refine over time.
Nevertheless, I'd like to introduce you to all of the features, so
that when you need them you're aware that they're there. UML class diagrams
are also sometimes called Static Structure Diagrams. They're one of UML's
structure diagrams as opposed to the diagrams which you used to model behavior.
Despite being called Class Model Diagrams, besides classes, they also have
iconic representations for interfaces, objects, relationships, and so on.
The official specification for UML can be found on the Class Resources page.
And we're also going to be taking some examples from the UML reference manual,
which is referred to on the resources page as well.